where do we go here as from here as a
franchise it's kind of hard to say
rachel lindsey is sharing her reaction
to chris harrison
temporarily stepping away from his
bachelor hosting duties
chris has stepped aside which i think is
the right decision because
like he said he needs to take time to
get educated on a profound and
productive level to use his words
and i think he needs to understand what
was done what was wrong and what he said
in that interview
and he needs time he's a step away to do
that on saturday harrison
announced that he won't be hosting the
bachelor's upcoming after the final rose
special
following his controversial interview
with lindsay where he defended
current bachelor contestant rachel
corconell's alleged past
racist actions which included attending
an old south plantation themed party
while in college in 2018. well rachel
is it a good look in 2018 or is it not a
good look in 2021
because there's a big difference shortly
after that interview
aired harrison issued a statement
apologizing for quote
wrongly speaking in a manner that
perpetuates racism
and while lindsay said it's been tough
for her to accept his apology
it's a little hard for me because i
lived the experience
i walked away there was no apology the
apology came after the fact
she also says she doesn't want to be too
quick to judge him
he has taken the steps to not issue one
but two apologies
let's see what happens from there the
former bachelorette also pointed out
that many members of bachelor nation
have spoken out against harrison's
comments
including the women from the current
season of the bachelor
who issued a joint statement to see the
contestants come together and speak
out and to say what they don't stand for
i don't know how we continue in this way
how do you when people in bachelor
nation are upset the contestants of this
very show
the leads of the show how does he go on
to represent the franchise when people
are so upset
by what they saw in that interview it's
a sentiment
lindsay previously shared on friday
during an interview with good morning
america
you have the face the spokesperson
of that franchise say the things that
were said this week
and it lets you know the work isn't done
and on thursday she called for action
when she
opened up about harrison's apology on
her podcast with van lathan
hired learning he said i promise to do
better
i need people to stop making these
statements what does that look like
what does doing better look like how are
you going to be better that is what i
want to know
you putting out a statement and
disappearing for a few days
weeks that ain't better how is chris
harrison going to be better
while recording the podcast kirknell's
public apology was released
lindsay had this to say an apology
is a step baby step in the right
direction
but it's just an apology we gotta see it
i'm now i'm holding you to what you said
you